we're gonna bring up to incredible
endurance athletes and two dear friends
Hilary Biscay who's an Ironman champion
and an Ultraman champion who's known for
being one of the toughest athletes on
the Ironman tour and it also happens to
be a childhood friend of my wife and
sister-in-law
needless to say Hillary became the
better athlete and then rich who is also
a dear friend and did this insane thing
called epic five where he did five Iron
Man's on five different Hawaiian Islands
in seven days and just has an incredible
story so like if we're talking about
achieving peak performance it doesn't
get better than these two so we're gonna
we're gonna welcome welcome that
so I'll start with with you rich you
know we're talking about time and so
many of us don't have time and we want
to do something for 30 minutes in terms
of exercise that's all I got what do you
recommend to anyone out there what would
you do you got thirty minutes that's all
you can do well I think the thing is the
most important thing is to just engage
in something that makes you feel happy
that involves moving your body and I
think what happens is we get really
caught up in this idea of where is it
gonna lead me like oh I want to run a
marathon or you pick some goal and you
want to have it all figured out in your
mind how you're gonna get there and and
what happens is that results in
paralysis for a lot of people because
they can't like they want to know the
perfect running shoe before they even go
outside and take a walk so my advice is
always just go outside and do something
you know engage with your body in a way
that helps you sort of connect with
yourself a little bit more and to find
something that's fun for you if you hate
running do something that you enjoy so
you got to like it yeah you got to like
it it's not about thirty minutes or five
hours it's about just the the fact of
actually doing it and following through
and so for Hillary your races last four
hours like how long is an Ironman
between nine and ten oh nine ten hours
that's a long time so like do you ever
mentally while you're doing this you're
you're going through agony or pain you
ever just get like bored or like you
just want to like stop and cry or just
go leave or like how do you does that
ever happen oh yeah literally even on my
very best days and I think I speak for
everyone in my sort of all of my peers
and I say this even on my very best days
at the races I hit one of those moments
at least once it's just simply too long
that it's not possible to never go into
the valley over nine or ten hours right
you have your peaks and you have your
valleys and on a good day you have less
valleys and peaks but absolutely I hit
that point of I don't know if I can
finish I
stop I want to sit down and cry that
kind of thing at least once and and I
think that it's conquering those moments
of something just that just comes with
practice it was like now I've done as of
last weekend 66 Iron Man's so I will
myself I think that like the severity of
those moments is lessened to a certain
degree with each one just because I've
now proved 66 times over that no matter
what is thrown my way on the day and a
lot of things have been thrown my way
I'll always get to the finish line so I
know that there's a light at the end of
the tunnel tunnel and I'll come out of
it was there a certain number when you
got over the hump like we were like I
know I can was it five or forty six no I
mean honestly one of my most trying Iron
Man's was number 64 so it's just two
months ago and it presented some of the
biggest challenges I've ever had but
because I was at number 64 those
challenges I may not have been able to
handle it at number 20 but I had over
the course of the last 40 or so I
developed tools you know to deal with
those right I like that she's done three
Iron Man's in the last two months so
this question is for both of you I'll
start with you rich do you think you you
are born mentally tough or physically
gifted or is it something you had to
work on no I think it's something you
have to you have to work on I mean I
think it's easy it's it's easier to be
mentally tough when what you're pursuing
is something that you're passionate
right I mean I think that if you're
trying to be mentally tough about you
know a job you don't like or something
he really doesn't feel like is you
inherently then it's a lot harder to
adhere to a schedule or kind of follow
through on stepping-stone goals but when
you have a passion when you have
something that truly moves you Ament
mentally emotionally and spiritually
it's it's a lot easier but I think that
you know my experience my personal
experience has always been that you know
I was never the smartest kid I was never
the most athletically talented all these
sort of things and I realized at a very
young age that if I wanted to kind of
compete with you know sort of the people
that I looked up to that I was going to
have to go the extra mile and I was a
very conscious decision that I've made
a young age that served me it's also
letting me sit down some dark alleyways
well but uh but um but I think it's a
discipline just like anything else what
about you Hilary tell me one more time
I'm sorry
so do you think you were born mentally
tougher physically gifted something you
had to work on or is it a little
combination I'm nodding listening to
Rich's response because I fell like I
feel like we're like athletic soulmates
in that way because I've always sort of
been of that of the same mindset that he
described like even as a young kid on my
background is in swimming right and I
was actually calling and Kerry Jason's
Jason's wife and sister-in-law and all
my peers in fact were kind of lightyears
ahead of me for much of my young
swimming career but I think that yeah I
always just felt like if I if I work
hard or I can catch up and I guess maybe
I've had so many coaches along the way
sort of told me that I thought I was
lacking in talent that the one thing
that I and I understood that you were
born with that but the one thing that I
think I also understood early that I
could cultivate was that like mental
toughness and so that was something that
I worked on so what do you guys do when
you're in a slump whether it's training
or in life do you have how do you apply
those roles of training and competing
when you're in a slump to life to
everything you do I think the the main
kind of rule of thumb that I rely on is
this idea that you can't think your way
out of those situations you can only act
your way out of those situations and
what I mean by that is essentially that
if I'm feeling depressed or sorry for
myself or I'm tired I don't want to get
up and do my workout or whatever it is I
have to do that day it's very easy like
my default and I think the sort of
common default mental position is to go
well just wait until I feel better or
like you know wait till a little later
on I'll then I'll get to it you know
when my emotions shift and you have to
realize that mood follows action it's
not the other way around
so when you take the action in spite of
however you feel realizing it's just how
I feel it's just a feeling it's not
gonna kill me I can feel it and then to
take action in contrast to that and you
that's how you shift how you feel about
that scenario and that's how I get out
of those sort of holes that I can dig
for myself whether they're physical or
emotional how do you get exactly the
same way I I mean one of the things
fitness I found and sort of like it
maybe yeah
athletic fitness is is something that we
constantly have to be working on so
there are always you know there there
there's a time in every season and year
when even as a professional athlete we
take some downtime and you when you
start coming back you you feel this like
everything feels terrible and when
things feel terrible you don't feel like
getting out the door to go for a run
because it suddenly feels a lot harder
than normal and yeah what I've learned
is exactly as Rick described like
there's no way to get through it other
than to go through it like you literally
have to work through it when you don't
want to do the workout when it doesn't
feel good you know it's not gonna feel
good it's literally forcing myself out
the door to start the workout every day
for weeks until that like good feeling
comes back I would I would add to that
also you know a big theme of today has
been meditation and kind of
understanding the difference or the
distinction between kind of your higher
self and a chatter of your thinking mind
right and your thinking mind is going
you can sleep in you know don't get out
of bed do all that kind of stuff and and
when you when you are meditating or you
have developed like enough of that
awareness or consciousness you can go
oh that's just that guy over there
saying that like I don't have to listen
to that right I don't have to engage in
that I can actually turn that off and
just put one foot in front of the other
regardless of how I feel or whatever my
mind is saying and before I know it like
I'm in the swimming pool or I'm you know
I've taken the first step on that run
that I really didn't want to do that day
and so I want to get back to this idea
of like training and applying the rules
of training to life like is there is
there separation for either of you do
those rules apply to everything you do I
think so and people who deal with me in
business probably get really annoyed
with that
but but to me it's yeah I guess
something that they're really sort of
transcends across like my entire life is
you know how are we gonna how are we
gonna tell me what we need to make like
we're talking about we're gonna need to
make happen say it's in business or
whatever else and I just want to figure
out how we're gonna make it happen I
have no time don't want to talk about
the excuses and things that are in our
way let's just be like solution oriented
how am I gonna get my foot out the door
to start that run at 4:30 this morning
my alarm goes off how are we going to
solve this problem how are we going to
deliver this this product that kind of
thing it's sort of like all eyes on the
prize and I don't want to I don't want
to do I don't want to think about like
you know any obstacles let's just like
figure out how we're gonna make
something happen and that's what happens
with training and that's yeah what I try
to apply to everything else in life
right so what is that sense of it you
know I think we all you know and hearing
some of the things you've done like what
is that sense of accomplishment feel
like when you know after epic five after
Ultraman after you've done something
like do you'd feel if we talked about
the mind-body connection let's talk
about how you physically you've just
done something that's amazing how does
that inspire you to well I think that I
feel like the volume gets turned up so
gradually you know so for its it's
natural for Hillary to go yeah I've done
66 Iron Man's you know like what's the
big deal right because that is a process
that you know took a lot of times
there's been a lot of work so it's
normal for her anyway so you know epic
five or altra man are these other races
it's similar you know when I first
started out the idea of running a
marathon seemed insane you know and then
you know I remember the first time I did
a 40 mile training run and it like blew
my mind but it's because it just was a
very gradual progression route so that
by the time I did epic five when I was
done with that I was like okay I did
that and I and I don't and a big thing
like a big thing that I always talked
about and I always try to hammer home is
is you know I'm not focused on those
finish lines or those destinations it's
not about like how I feel when I cross
the finish line because when I think
back on those experiences I don't it's
it's kind of like that's a blur but what
I remember is that morning you know that
I didn't want to get out of that and I
did
anyway to put the training in it's like
those little things along those pearls
those little like beads of wisdom that
you accumulate along the path along the
journey and that's what I think about
and that's what I value and and the sort
of the race or whatever it is is just
the icing on the cake it's like the
physical manifestation of what got you
to that place and so I'm gonna switch
gears a little bit and everyone always
wants to know like what you guys eat
like what's in your pantry how do you
feel like what's if we walk into your
kitchen right now what's what's in there
what's in the fridge what's in the
pantry go oh my goodness lots of coffee
I know he won't agree with that my
husband just delivered me a quad shot
soy latte so there's a lot of that and I
and my pantry is is in terms of my food
I can't speak for the entire family but
there just aren't any animal products
and that that's for me a really big
thing it was not a thematic ly motivated
it was epically motivated I love animals
so for me I just I don't consume any
animal products in my in my life nor do
I consume gluten so there's like it
seems like a lot of rules but it's
actually super easy one hand when you
get used to it and so I just I try to
eat as much like as many living things
as I can um in terms of you know grain
things and vegetables and fruits and and
all of that I think that I also if I
weren't a person I would be like a big
garbanzo bean because that's that that's
my thing I eat garbanzo beans I eat them
by the pound and hummus yes what about
you rich
yeah it's very similar I mean I've been
100% plant-based for coming up on about
eight years now
and that's really what revitalized
revitalized my body mind and soul that
has allowed me to go on and and
participate in these crazy endurance
races so it's very similar to the way
that Hillary eats but you know I'm a
husband and a father of four we have a
busy house lots of kids and and so what
I eat is what my kids eat what my wife
my beautiful wife Julie who's an amazing
cook right here that she prepares for
for all of us but it's generally just
tons of healthy fruits vegetables
legumes nuts seeds and whole grains in
all kinds of varieties of a big
proponent of blended smoothies you know
I start my morning with that my
breakfast is usually like essentially
drinking salad and what's in there yeah
it's everybody's always like what's the
secret you know what it would be in the
morning you know but it quite honestly
the truth is is that it just depends on
what's on our refrigerator or pantry
that day you know with with six people
in our house I never you know we can't
we're not always it fully up to stock on
everything but it always starts out with
dark leafy green so that would mean like
kale spinach
you know beet greens chard and then from
there maybe some broccoli I said spinach
beets celery and then some berries like
you know high in antioxidant berries and
some superfoods hemp seeds you know chia
seeds flax seeds it's every day's
different you know but and and the way
that I'd make them they always end up
tasting the same no matter what's in
yours what smoothie you know Julie knows
how to make them taste really good I
just I just did a show up and drink it
yeah very similar kinds of plant-based
foods you know yeah lots of green stuff
I like to just cram as much green stuff
and vegetables like I put zucchini in
there and carrots because I just think
it's simply impossible just chew as much
of that stuff as we actually need so I
like to disguise as much of it as I can
and a smoothie with berries and frozen
bananas and stuff that's like sweet yeah
yeah so it's just about maximizing the
Vitamix capacity and like how many
nutrients kind of pack into one
you're both making me very thirsty you
hungry right now well thank you so much
for for coming and sharing a bit about
what you do yeah thank you